What happened to post modernism,
that great intellectual movement of the
late 20th century,
that question all objective conceptions
of truth.
What happened to it?
Did it end?
Most people seem to agree that yet it
did end,
but if you ask those same people when
postmodernism ended,
they can't really give you an answer.
This may be due to the fact that the
idea of postmodernism is still pretty
fun.
It's hard to define it except as a
reaction to the modernism.
It was created to refute that.
Simplest way I can describe it is like
this.
Modernism was a movement at the turn of
the 20th century dedicated to building
coherent theories about all the new
information science,
philosophy and psychology or giving to
us,
and postmodernism was the period
directly after that in which the
authority of all those theories was
challenged as well as the very notion of
authority in the first place.
Postmodernism is a good catchall for all
the various and chaotic ways of thinking
that characterize the later part of the
20th century.
But as we neared the millennials and the
need to react to or refute modernism
seemed less and less relevant,
postmodernism sort of fell apart and we
were left with,
well nothing indeed.
One of the key characteristics of our
time is its inability to define itself
with a set of intellectual ideas.
Why is this?
Why have categories like this broken
down?
Why don't they seem to suit the
contemporary age?
Is it because everything is just too
chaotic now?
Or is it because we have too much
information and too much access for any
one movement to congeal and rise to
prominence?
Yeah,
I think that's probably true,
but it only tells us so much.
If we dig a little bit deeper,
we can see that what's really changed is
our relationship to history as science
fiction author Bruce Sterling,
one set history is not a science.
History is an effort and the humanities.
What sterling means is that history,
studying it or writing it or knowing it
has always been a game of meanings.
We look back in based on certain
material facts and contemporary
writings.
Try to tell a coherent story about past
cultures and their values,
the meanings they ascribe to their time
and existence.
Now,
modernism and postmodernism had
something in common there.
Access to history was enabled by paper,
by books,
books with covers and bindings,
but more importantly with beginnings,
middles and ends.
Modernists and postmodernists thinkers
had to resort to books.
They had no other choice.
They learned the authoritative sources
on a given subject either to accept or
refute them and by responding to the
tradition they themselves became a part
of it,
but these are different times.
The book was replaced,
it was replaced with the network and the
network doesn't respect history or
tradition.
Let's say you want to know something
about,
I don't know the philosophy of stoicism.
I bet the very first thing you would do
is open up a search engine,
probably Google and let a complex ever
changing algorithm based on views,
recency,
filters,
phrasing and much more prioritize.
A list of results within that list are
all kinds of different and contradictory
positions all the way from top
university professors to some guy on his
couch and in each article there is
usually a common section with opinions
about those opinions.
Then if you can find the author's name,
you can go back to Google and type that
in,
see if you can somehow determine via
their wikipedia page or number of
twitter followers what other people
consider the level of their authenticity
to be,
or you can just go to youtube,
which I often do and see if someone's
made a video about stoicism.
That's a little bit easier to digest.
In the network culture.
Everything is fluid,
poorly organized,
but extremely persuasive.
Narratives accumulate,
alter and change as quickly as Google's
algorithm does and we have access to all
of them instantaneously.
Sterling and fellow author,
William Gibson name this unnameable
transition period of culture.
A temporality in which we have this
great unmooring from historical
knowledge just makes for a lot of unease
and our time,
the maps we have,
the network,
the Internet,
and all its social function can't seem
to do its job.
It can't map a strong master narrative
onto the world we see in front of us
now,
maybe someday it will.
Sterling gives it 10 years,
but it won't look like any of the master
narratives from literary culture.
Really we have no idea what a master
narrative in network culture could look
like.
Now.
It's easy to see that such a disruptive
break from the past also means and
uncertainty about the future,
about what progress looks like,
a lack of confidence in the market in
nation states,
in groups of nation states like the EU
and the belief that democracy can be
exported around the globe are all
symptomatic of this.
A temporal transition period in the
world and in the arts.
What you get is this collaging of past
and future in the present,
the repurposing of old structures and
obsessions with predicted futures of the
past.
That never came about.
I mean,
what's more out of time,
for example,
then stuff like steam punk.
It's tempting to see this new historical
situation as a problem,
but you can look at it as an opportunity
to why not take up the whirling elements
of the past and the future and design
the contemporary moment that you want to
see in art,
in your personal life or in the public
space.
Then maybe the highbrow philosophy of
the future can't be canonized.
Maybe there never will be another
Charles Dickens or George Orwell,
but there's a great freedom in losing
the Canon as well as sterling notes.
Historians really used to worry that
their interpretations of the past were
clouded by their own values.
Maybe the good news is that for us right
now,
we just don't know what our values
really are so that whether we're looking
back or looking forward,
the a temporal age and the a temporal
person can finally see with clear eyes.
I want to thank everybody so much.
Who is pledged to the channel on
Patrion.
You're really making this possible.
You know,
I do this full time now and I've had
such a great time focusing all my energy
and effort on making I hope really,
really great content for you and there's
a lot more coming up.
So if you haven't already,
I want to ask you please to pledge to
the nerd writer on Patrion as little as
$1 per video.
Everything helps.
I mean,
if a bunch of people do $1,
it adds up.
So don't be afraid to do a little if you
only have a little.
Thank you so much.
I'm going to keep bringing stuff to you
next Wednesday and if you want to check
out my last understanding art,
which is a poetry analysis,
click around here.
It's about later and the swan by WB
yeats,
one of my favorite poems ever.
And I love that video.
So,
um,
thank you so much again and I'll see you
next time.